see most salespeople they believe in
this nonsense that if they just think
positively nothing bad would happen to
them so what do you say when your
clients ask you the question well how
much do you charge how much is it
remember facts tell stories sell
Juanes or get a mentor what's up bleep
nation it's evan i believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so today
let's learn from one of the best day in
Locke and his steps to becoming a sales
expert mentor me Dan also if you want to
know what Dan and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence to live the join is in
the description below after you practice
martial art you develop this natural
self confidence not cockiness but you
develop this natural self-confidence
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't be a typical salesperson you
see more salespeople they always believe
in the conventional wisdom in order to
be a great salesperson what do you have
to do you have to have enthusiasm you
gotta be excited about your product hey
man is it this is my product is so good
don't you know we are the best in the
world this would help you this will help
your company you should buy it from me
enthusiasm because they are taught if
you're not enthusiastic about your
product or service and then the prospect
won't be enthusiastic either or what I
call pretentious bonding hey you know
how your kids yeah how's the weather how
how's work you don't give a [ __ ]
you know your prospect doesn't give it
but it's pretentious bonding or oh you
got a follow-up man
you know they buy or they die right you
fall up 5 10 30 times you gotta be
persistent you got to keep calling keep
calling keep chasing them or you gotta
ask for the sale three times the error
sell prospect you gotta ask them seven
times before they buy I don't like to
ask for the sell
I want the prospect that give me the
cell it's better to receive that a bag
or you got to chase the prospect you got
to keep pleasing them chase them I don't
like to chase them I like to be the
chase so how do you become a great
salesperson today I'm gonna give you one
of the most important lessons that I
have learned in order to be a great
salesperson
and that is now this may sound
counterintuitive that is in order to be
a great salesperson
you cannot be a salesperson
dan what are you talking about I want
you think about in a society when I say
the word sales what comes to mind when I
say the word salesperson what comes to
mind
comment below no filter don't think
about it just comment below sales or
salesperson what comes to mind snake oil
pushy aggressive used-car salesman
manipulation right just do it for the
money
once your commission all that stuff
right imagine if you have kids imagine
if you I parent mom and dad your kid
goes home and walks up to you and say
hey dad daddy mommy when I grow up I
want to be a doctor and you're like oh
my god dad I'm so proud of you you know
I raise you well it's good if you're
talk to him right imagine different
scenario your kid comes home and says
dear mommy and daddy when I grew up I
want to be a Salesman and you're like oh
my god what did I do this is how I
raised you
I fail I fail as a parent what did I do
right just think about that so it's
perfectly okay to get into student loan
to spend six eight years in medical
school right to pay a highly stressful
profession don't get me wrong I have a
lot of respect for doctors but somehow
when your kid comes home and say I want
to be a salesperson is all it is such a
profession that being looked down upon
that is a profession that is like no
that is not a real job and it's not a
real career when in fact some of the
highest pay people in our society guess
what
they're salespeople Warren Buffett
it's a salesperson Elon Musk is a
salesperson when Elon Musk is announcing
the new Tesla guess what he is closing
it's a closer he's selling right when
Warren Buffett at the shareholder
meeting talks about the division talk
about what they're gonna do talk about
the report talk about the earnings guess
what he is selling so you invest in a
stock remember Steve Jobs when he was
announcing the new iPhone the new iPod
in front of thousands and thousands of
people live in worldwide the whole world
is watching
guess what he is closing that is a sales
presentation it's not a product
announcement it's a sales presentation
they are all closers they all sales
people so how do you become a great
salesperson don't sound and act and talk
like a typical salesperson if a typical
salesperson it's like hey hey how are
you sir don't do that become be neutral
sound like to talk to imagine that you
are a doctor
can you imagine go to a doctor and your
doctor says to you how are you so glad
you could come in how do you feel you
have a fever
hey no worry man you know what I I can
do it prescription in fact this
prescription you buy one you get one
free man is so good you win you want me
to follow with you if you see a doctor
and the doctor sounds like that what do
you do you run there's something wrong
with this guy
right be the doctor calm neutral don't
chase be the chase be a problem-solver
ask questions discover their needs be a
professional you tell me a little bit
about your situation tell me about your
business
let's bottom line just tell me how you
and I can do business today what are we
hoping to get for me today see that's a
professional that's how you should
behave and talk your tonality you speak
with conviction and authority
you're not attached to yourself it's
okay if you don't get to sell see when
you're not desperate now the prospect
they open they open up to you now they
want to hear okay this person wants to
help me not just going after the money
or that Commission check or that a quick
buck that this person is a professional
that you are a professional that's how
you sell your way through life that's
how you get what you want in life by
first helping others to get what they
want then you can get everything that
you want it is that simple
rule number two be well prepared yeah
yeah we do charge a little bit more
money but we do really good work I mean
we always try to to serve our clients
and do you want to send me an email on
the back to follow up maybe touch basics
three three months from now is that okay
no that's not what a closers just sound
like so how do you develop confidence in
selves you see most salespeople they
believe in this nonsense that if they
just think positively nothing bad would
happen to them then if they go into a
sales meeting they gonna sales call and
they are positive and everything will be
fine what it's like believing the idea
if you are positive and you go into a
boxing ring without preparation you
won't get knocked out
it's a stupid as that you see when it
comes to closing when it comes to sales
I don't believe in positive thinking I
believe in the positive power of
negative preparation what he means is I
want to think of that that's like a
chess game that when you're going in to
play a chess game what differentiate a
an amateur a chess player versus a
master chess player is what the master
chess player knows ten steps ahead
that's what makes that person a master
chess player what do you want to do as a
closer as a salesperson it's going into
every single situation every single
sales conversation be well prepared so
you know every single object
then your prospect might have and you
know exactly how to handle it and that's
how you get confidence
you see lack of confidence comes from
lack of operation what you want to do is
you want to practice you want to
practice and roleplay until you're sick
and tired of it and then guess what you
practice some more rule number three use
stories number three people don't buy
products and services they buy stories
because when there are so many choices
out there the marketplace on the
internet any any any product that you
want
there are hundreds and hundreds of
choices how do you stand out how do you
add emotions to a commodity a pen what's
the difference between a two dollar pen
like this or a an 800 dollar Montblanc
John F Kennedy limited edition exclusive
pen $800 of him it's the same pen it's
the same functions story when he asked
story to it to an item suddenly when you
add the the the John F Kennedy the
president story attached to a brand to a
logo it is 10 times more valuable it is
a hundred times more valuable it is 300
times more valuable that particular pen
all because a story he writes the same a
$2.00 pen you can write to that's the
difference so think about what was the
story
how can you inject stories into
everything at YouTube may be the origin
story how did you get started why do you
do what you do what have also stories of
your customers remember facts tell
stories sell facts tell story sell rule
number four control the conversation so
what do you say when your clients ask
you the question well how much do you
charge how much is it
what's your response how do you handle
this objection now before I teach you
exactly how the head of this objection
you have to understand why they're
asking that and when they're asking is
also very critical example if they're
asking you this question how much is it
you're just two or three five minutes
into your conversation
it could be on the phone could be face
to face it means that they want to get
to the bottom line they want to know
just tell me how much it is I don't I
don't care or your feature benefit I
just want to know what this fits my
budget now the minute you give out the
price you tell them this is how much
you've lost all control because you have
not taken the time to build up the knees
to discover exactly what they're looking
for before you give to the price so when
you tell them the price they say is
$10,000 it's $50,000 it's $100,000 right
there at the minute you gave them the
price you've lost your power because now
all you could do is wait for your client
and say you know what no that's so
expensive no I don't want to pay for
that oh no that's that's that's not what
we thought that we're gonna spend then
we're gonna do now you have to go into
what I call justification mode right oh
but but we are so good that our product
is better than we've been in business
for X amount of years and
and all this now you turn into this
salesperson right you don't want to do
that so if it's in the very beginning of
the conversation when your clients
asking you so how much is it exactly you
should redirect we direct the
conversation going back to the needs and
find exactly why are they talking with
you in the first place
so in the beginning when they asked you
the question how much is it you would
simply reply it depends it depends and
then they might say something like all
depends on what well it depends on
exactly what you're looking for so why
don't you tell me a little bit about
what you're looking for
boom you go back to their needs you go
back to their wants you go back to you
why are they talking to in the first
place now if it's somewhere and let's
say after the middle of the conversation
it's the end and you've done everything
that I teach you they you are qualifying
them you find out about their needs
you've done all those steps and now it's
more near the end you are actually
talking about money and they say well
how much is it now whenever you give
them a price let's say is $10,000 you
don't just say well how much is it or
$10,000 oh and they're all they gonna
say is either it's okay but most people
they would say oh it's too expensive
it's more than I thought
it's a natural response from your buyer
so what do you do you want to also
continuously ask the next question so it
would sound something like this
well how much is it it's $10,000 are you
comfortable spending that kind of money
or it's $10,000 is that within your
budget so right there you take the next
question and you go deeper right you go
to the next step and they won't deal
they'll say yes or they say no now if
they are giving your resistance on price
and that goes beyond in this particular
video this is what I what I teach in
high ticket closures I teach you how to
handle some of those objections but for
now for now knowing that if they ask you
that question you always want to
redirect you don't really just want to
say well the price without something
else sometimes if it's up it was
somewhere in the middle of the
conversation they asked you were how
much does it cost if they are pushing
and pushing and pushing you can also get
them a range you give them a range of oh
it's it depends on what you need let's
say you are a a graphic design person
and you are developing a logo or a brand
or something for them and they asking
well how much is it gonna cost me to you
four to do all these design packages and
all that well you know anywhere from
five to ten thousand dollars how do you
feel about that and it's just listened
and see what they have to say now they
might say oh okay that's what we were
thinking roughly to spend okay or they
might say oh wow that's well hold on a
second that's way more than what we want
to spend then you can go back to
handling the objection so be very very
careful when your prospects asking you
how much is it so depends on when
depends on the timing you will handle it
differently and rule number five the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is provide a great experience and
the last day which I believe is actually
one of the most important steps and that
is delivery and fulfillment so now you
have closed a sale you've qualified the
leads how are you going to deliver the
outcome that you promised to the
prospect what what is the what are the
deliver
what are you gonna do because this is
where you get the referrals this is how
you get to repeat business see most
organizations the only focus on the
first couple steps or maybe step number
four just want to close the sale doesn't
stop after you close the sells starts
after you close the prospect and then
from the buyers journey perspective that
is what I call experience that's the
last step what is the experience you're
providing for the buyer for your client
this is extremely critical because
you've done all this work during this
sales process
1 2 3 4 5 don't screw it up in that last
step
now I've got a bonus clip from Dan on
how to master your craft that I think
you're gonna really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go
question number one how can you use
stories better in your sales process
number two when do you usually lose
control of the conversation and how will
you fix it and number three what's the
great experience that you want to
provide your customers
one two so you're talking 1,500 to 2,000
a month with local clients how much do
you want to be talking and what's the
cost of delivering the service it's easy
you know both three hundred dollars for
an account manager then you hundred
dollars a month for a you know somebody
to just maintain the Facebook Ads after
I create them so you know maybe you know
with everything else entailed on maybe
seven others so fifty percent right now
goddess so you're talking fifteen
hundred and you are your cost is seven
250 and how many clothes you're working
with right now I've got about 13 clients
you know been at it for a few years now
it's a smart skill okay how many clients
do you want to be working with well the
goal is you know I think the first
milestone I need to get to is 50 but
long-term I'd like a hundred clients
would be even better so and then so what
we're hoping to get for me today usually
I start with two hours because with what
you're doing right now I think two hours
would be sufficient enough to let me
look at your offer we package your
service a bit and also may give you some
strategies on how to palm up your your
pricing because I think you're not
charging enough cuz let's face it with
right now with a 50% profit margin you
will have a problem when you grow
because as you bring on more people your
your mod profit margin will shrink and
quite frankly there's not enough no one
day - will I with Burroughs because you
cannot afford to spend money on
marketing true yeah
so four for two hours are charged 10k
out of you about that correct five
thousand an hour it's awful lot of money
[Music]
a lot of money let me ask you this
you're coming to me because you want to
charge more money and charge what you
believe you're worth in and have more
just make more profit correct yeah and
how would you feel you are now you come
to meet a king of high ticket sales damn
log and we start our relationship by me
giving a discount would you trust you
would you trust a high guy like that to
help you increase your price do you want
to be the most extreme wannabe Bentley
in your industry or you want to be the
[Music]
correct so you want to cut like half
down halfway complete it is a two-hour
commitment you okay okay with that right
but because cashflow I get it up in
there when I even when I was starting my
business
so you're saying 5,000 maybe this month
and a 5,000 next month correct let's
pretend I was to accept that offer what
would you say to me are you sure you
don't sound like very servant because I
don't want you to do this if you're not
sure but it's alright because I'm gonna
help you but damn you got to do the work
[Laughter]
[Music]
so you sure you want to do this yes
you're not gonna come back to me and say
change your mind tomorrow cuz if that's
the case I don't want to waste your time
I definitely want to waste my time and
I'm gonna give you the strategies I
don't even mind we don't have to do the
two-hour call upfront I can do the first
hour call and then we can do even the
second call thirty minute thirty minute
because I want to make sure out the time
we spend together is productive yeah
we're not wasting time shooting the
breeze and talking about the weather
right yeah okay so so what do you want
to do
well I guess how do i holiday we can do
we can do we're gonna take credit card
you can do PayPal we can do wire
transfer my credit cards are locked up
but I could do PayPal if there's
something for that sure sure so here's
what I'll do I'll get my assistant to
you to send you an email with a simple
simple agreement I don't do long 10 page
contract very short you can fill that
out get back to me with that and then
also I'll have her include a PayPal link
with 5,000 down and 5,000 in 30 days
sound good yeah Kevin congratulations
I love for working with you okay and
relax take a deep breath we gonna take a
visit on next level as long as you're
coachable we're gonna do it you got it
you guys so look for that email okay
okay sounds good have a great day okay
goodbye
hi this is Dan lock if you're a fan of
Evans work if you want to know exactly
how the model my success I want to
invite you to join me for a special
online training all you have to do is
click on a link below you can join me
for absolutely no charge so click a link
below and I will see you in class
if you want more dan lock check at the
top 10 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there it is a habit so it
is staying poor it's also not an act
it's nothing just happens to you it is a
habit